Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Spit out your gum, put down that toad and
follow a rainbow to the wishing well.
Swallowed chewing gum doesn’t stay in your
stomach for seven years.
Since your teeth don’t break down gum like
food, fears arose that stomachs had similar
trouble processing it.
But it really just passes through your system
like the outside fiber shell of corn.
Swallowing several pieces of gum a day, however,
could develop a bezoar - a hard mass that
clogs the digestive tract.
In severe cases, surgery is needed to remove
the blockage, and the disimpaction procedure
is described in a medical journal as like
a taffy-pull.
Touching a toad will not give you warts.
Toads are covered in wart-like bumps that
help them blend into their environments, but
warts on humans are a virus.
The problem was that no one before 1892 knew
what a virus was, so the transmission of warts
through toad-handling was a common explanation.
Methods for getting rid of warts often involved
rubbing something on them like a bean pod,
piece of beef or your mother’s dish rag
and then burying it - and as the item rotted
away - so apparently went the wart.
In reality, warts can suddenly disappear on
their own due to the nature of the human papillomavirus,
so many bizarre wart remedies like dripping
eel blood or blowing on it nine times under
the full moon were believed to really work.
Tossing coins in water fountains and ponds
for good luck comes from the tradition of
wishing wells.
Ancient Germanic and Celtic people thought
that by offering gifts like pins or coins
to the water deities that lived in wells,
they would be granted their wish -- which
often was about finding a sweetheart.
And while the wishes may not have always been
granted, pure silver and pure copper coins
tossed into wells may have been making the
water safer to drink.
Silver kills bacteria in water - it’s been
used as a water disinfecting agent on the
International Space Station.
And a 2012 study shows storing drinking water
in copper pots can also kill certain harmful
bacteria.
Therefore, Helga’s wish for a boyfriend
may have prevented her village from getting
diarrhea.
But silver and copper coins are no gold.
According to Irish folklore, just visit the
end of a rainbow to find a pot of gold guarded
by a Leprechaun.
Unfortunately, you can never reach the end
of a rainbow because seeing a rainbow requires
you to be a distance away from it so that
sunlight can refract off water droplets and
hit your eyes.
After Vikings invaded Ireland around the 10th
century they left behind hordes of treasure
which are supposedly guarded by Leprechauns
to prevent greedy humans from fighting over
it.
A metal detector recently uncovered over a
hundred silver and gold Viking artifacts near
the coast of the Irish Sea.
So a bit of science and technology were all
that was needed to get those lucky charms.
And as always -
thanks for watching!